air france les personnels d'entretien
poursuivre la grève
résultat dix avions bloqués au sol faute
des réparations nécessaires
françoise joly dans cet atelier d'air
france
ils sont plusieurs dizaines de
mécaniciens ouvriers agents d'entretien
à faire la toilette de ce 747 une
révision complète classique qui va durer
cinq semaines
mais depuis 19 jours maintenant un tiers
des mécaniciens au sol d'air france fait
la grève une heure par jour
leur revendication 1500 francs de plus
par mois et une augmentation des
effectifs
quand je suis rentré en juin 1900
personnes disent je gagnais le double du
solide
aujourd'hui j'ai ma feuille de paye joe
gaïa 7554 francs et le smi est à 4100
sont franck comme quoi deux ans et robin
ans d'ancienneté donc j'ai perdu
considérablement de pouvoir d'achat
quand je travaille est importante et les
avez les effectifs sont pas du tout
le risque pour la charge de travail leur
ce qui fait que
travail
voyez bits
et pas toujours
sécurité conséquence de cette grève 10
avions d'air france sont immobilisés au
sol deux vols ont déjà été supprimés
aujourd'hui la direction d'air france
elle ne souhaite pas s'exprimer sur ce
conflit mais elle fait savoir que les
salaires ont déjà été augmentés de 2% en
octobre et qu'il envisage d'embaucher
250 personnes lundi de nouvelles
négociations entre la direction les
syndicats sont prévues mais la direction
d'air france refuse dit elle de céder
aux revendications de crainte
d'augmenter fortement ses coûts avant le
marché unique de 93 qui mettrait à rude
épreuve les transports aériens français
face à la concurrence européenne